اعلن الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب ان
البحرين ستصبح ثاني بلد عربي خليجي بعد
الامارات تقيم علاقات رسميه مع اسرائيل
واشاد الرئيس الامريكي بالخطوه من جانب
البحرين والتي تاتي قبل يومين من استضافته
المقرره لقاده اسرائيل والامارات في
واشنطن للمشاركه في مراسم توقيع بالبيت
الابيض في هذه الفتره من السلام والتعاون
اتفق الزعيمان على ان تقيم البحرين علاقات
دبلوماسيه طبيعيه كامله مع اسرائيل البلد
سيتبادلان السفارات والسفراء وسيبدا في
تنظيم رحلات طيران مباشره بين البلدين
وسيد شنان تعاونا واسعا في مجالات وقطاعات
كثيره منها الصحه والتعليم والتكنولوجيا
والامن والزراعه ان هذا يوم
تاريخي وقال الرئيس الامريكي ان هناك دولا
اخرى في المنطقه تستعد لاعلان اقامه
علاقات دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل وتوقع ان
يحدث ذلك بسرعه
كبيره انه حقا حدث استثنائي مع تطبيع
المزيد من الدول علاقاتها مع اسرائيل وهو
ما سيحدث بسرعه كبيره نعتقد ان المنطقه
ستصبح اكثر استقرارا وامنا وازدهارا في
غضون ذلك نحن نسحب معظم جنودنا نعمل بشكل
مختلف عما اعتادوا القيام به عن طريق
القتال ولا شيء غيره وحيث كانت الدماء في
كل مكان كانت الرمال مليئه بالدماء والان
سترون ان السلام سيغطي الكثير من تلك
الرمال وستواصل الولايات المتحده الوقوف
الى جانب شعوب المنطقه وبناء مستقبل اكثر
اشراقا واكثر
تفاؤلا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
سان ديجو عبر الانترنت رون نيرين وهو رئيس
السابق للحزب الجمهوري في كاليفورنيا معنا
من رام الله واصل ابو يوسف عضو اللجنه
تنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه ومعنا
من واشنطن عبر الانترنت الدكتور توفيق
حميد الباحث والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم
جميعا ابدا معك دكتور عبد الحميد توفيق
يعني بدايه ضعنا في صوره اهميه هذه
الاتفاقات بالامس القريب اتفاق بين
الامارات واسرائيل واليوم البحرين اهميه
هذه الاتفاقات برايك لهذه
الدول شكرا سيد الك كريمه على سؤالك
الحقيقه في اكثر من عامل نقدر نقول هام في
هذه الاتفاقيات اول عامل ان
هو المنطقه مجرد ما يبقى في سلام في اي
منطقه بيبدا الاستثمارات الخارجيه بتتجه
ليها يعني لما اي مستثمرين من اللي هم
بيعملوا حاجه اسمها الفورن دايركت انست
اللي هو الاستثمار المباشر في الدول
الاخرى بيبقى له حسابات ولما يبقى المنطقه
فيها صراعات بيقل الاستثمار لما يبقى
المنطقه فيها سلام فكل ما يزيد السلام في
المنطقه ده هيجب لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
استثمارات اكثر ويعم الخير فعلا على
الجميع دي نمره واحد نمره اثنين ان في
عامل هام جدا وهو احقاق المنطق في الامور
ف في قاعده مشهوره جدا تقول ان اذا اذا
كرر الانسان نفس الشيء اكثر من مره فلا
ينتظر ان يحصل على نتيجه مختلفه
فالفلسطينيون او قيادتهم يعني بت رر نفس
الاتجاه في الحرب والعنف والصراع
واستمراره ولم تحصل الا على خساره في
الاراضي اكثر واكثر فالعقل يقول ان من
اهميه الامر هنا ان احنا نحكم العقل بان
احنا نغير الاسلوب لان الاسلوب الصراع ما
جابش نتيجه اما الامر الثالث فهو ان حينما
يتم تعاون ما بين هذه
الدول واسرائيل واحقاق سلام في بينهم دوله
زي ايران هتدرب انها لن تستطيع مجابهه كل
هؤلاء معا فممكن ده يجبرهم او ضغطهم
بطريقه يضطرهم لبدايه مرحله اخرى تكون
ايضا في اتجاه السلام فانا اعتقد ان له
اكثر من هدف من هدف اكثر من عامل تحدثت
عنه دكتور عبد الحميد والهدف الاهم الذي
تحدثت عنه هو احقاق المنطق كما تقول
وتغيير اسلوب يعني من الصراع الى اساليب
اخرى لكن اذا كانت هذه الاتف اتفاقيات
التطبيع ليست مبنيه على الارض مقابل
السلام اي سلام ستحققه للمنطقه
برايك السلام سيدتي الكريمه هو ما ياتي
بالارض وليس العكس يعني انور السادات عرض
السلام واخذ سينا واخذ قناه السويس واخذ
استثمارات سينا واخذ فوائد كثيره فاحنا كل
حسابات الماضي معتمده على ان الصراع هو
اللي بيجيب بيحل مشكله الارض في حين
التجربه الوحيده الناجحه كانت تجربه
الراحل انور السادات رحمه الله لما عرض
السلام واخد به ارض فاعتقد ان حان الوقت
للقيادات الفلسطينيه ان تعي هذا الدرس وان
تعرف ان الخطوه الاولى ان كانوا فعلا
يهتموا بقضيه الارض ان يعرضوا بيد مملوءه
بالسلام كما تعرض الدول اخرى في هذه
اللحظه قد تحل مشكله الارض طيب سيد رون
نيرين اذا كان السلام فعلا هو الذي ياتي
بالارض نعلم بانه كانت هناك رؤيه امريكيه
عرضها الرئيس الامريكي في مؤتمر البحرين
الاقتصادي كانت تتحدث
عن كانتونات كما يقول الفلسطينيون
كانتونات متفرقه تمنح للفلسطينيين تقع تحت
السلطه او السيطره الفلسطينيه هل يمكن
لهذه الكانتونات ان تشكل دوله وتاتي بهذه
الارض
الفلسطينيين
نعم هذا ممكن في نهايه المطاف بغض النظر
عن الوضع
النهائي الفلسطينيون يتعين ان يعتمدوا على
المفاوضات بينهم وبين
الاسرائيليين ان
المحاوله السابقه من قبل الاوروبيين
و الدول الاخرى التي تحدثت عن الضغوط
وتحدث عن معد الارهابي وما شاك ذلك لم
تجدي فتيله يتعين الحديث عن المفاوضات
الامر
غير مرتبط بالسلطه الفلسطينيه او منظمه
التحر الفلسطينيه ولكن حماس ايضا التي
لديها راي اخر تريد
ان تمحق اسرائيل والى ما هنالك صبكان ان
تفاوض مع شخص يريدك ميت ليس ثمه طرفان
هنالك اطراف وبالتالي مجددا يتعين التحلي
بالزعامه من قبل الفلسطين يتحدثوا باسم
الفلسطينيين بصوت واحد ولكي ياتوا الى
طوله المفاوضات ويتفاوض من خلال مسانده ق
خارجيه ولكن السلام لا يمكن ان يملى من
الخارج اذا كانت هذه الرؤيه الامريكيه
يعني قد
رفضتها يعني الكثير
من الشعوب يعني لاقت رفضا رسميا وشعبيا
كما طرحتها الولايات المتحده فكيف يمكن ان
تروج لها الولايات المتحده هل باعتقاد بان
مثل هذه الاتفاقات التطبيع مع بعض الدول
العربيه في المنطقه يمكن ان تؤتي
اقولها حسنا اعتقد ان هذا يعزز من الزخم
ويعزز من النهج المستقبلي ومن تقدم العالم
اعتقد ان اسرائيل
وربطها بجيرانها ودول عربيه من خلال
علاقات التجاره والدبلوماسيه يوفر
لاسرائيل
مساحه لتعزيز العلاقه مع هذه الدول اذا لم
يكن ثمه علاقات دبلوماسيه او تجاريه مع
دول الاخرى فان تلك الدول لن يكون لديها
ادوات فاعله وهذا برهن عليه منذ عام
1973 عندما مرت فكره القاء اسرائيل في
البحر ولكن في عام 1973 ذلك الحلم انحسر
اعتقد ان العالم يتقدم واعتقد ان
اسرائيل ذات
الروابط مع هذه الدول ماليا وتجاريا مرتبط
بتحول في الاطار المفاهيم الذي تحدث عنه
ضيفكم الكريم واعتقد ان هذا شيء ايجابي
اذا يعني شيء ايجابي وتحول في اطار
المفاهيم اتحول اليك سيد واصل ابو يوسف
يعني الفلسطينيون رفضوا هذه الاتفاقات
هناك سحب لسفير اليوم من البحرين على غرار
الخطوه الفلسطينيه تجاه الامارات اعتبروها
صفعه
وخيانه ما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين الان
التعامل مع هذه
الاتفاقات انا بعتقد ان الخيار الامثل هو
رفض كل ما له علاقه بهذا التطبيع الذي
يجري مع الاحتلال والذي يعطيه ضوء اخضر
الاستمرار في عدوانه وجرائمه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني معروف تماما ان تاتي ياتي هذا
التطبيع سواء من الامارات او اليوم من
البحرين في ظل ما يسمى صفقه القرن
الامريكيه الهادفه لتصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وفي ظل ايضا سياسه تصعيد
عدواني واجرام من قبل الاحتلال المتصاعد
سواء فيما يتعلق بالبناء والتوسع الاستع
مال الاستيطاني او سياسه التهويد وسياسه
تنقل الحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني وكل ذلك يعطي
اوراق قوه للاحتلال ربما لمحاكمه هذا
الامر لابد من العوده الى ما تحدث به رئيس
حكومه الاحتلال نتنياهو عندما تحدث عن ان
ثلاث متغيرات حدثت في اطار هذه الاتفاقات
المتغير الاول وهو ان الاتفاق يبنى على
اساس سلام مقابل سلام وليس على اساس سلام
مقابل انسحاب وارض وغير ذلك والامر الثاني
وهو ان كانت كلم عمليه السلام تتطلب ان
يكون هناك وقف الاستيطان الاستعمال
الاستيطاني وتفكيك المستعمرات الاستيطانيه
وايضا الحدود لدوله فلسطين الت قام عليها
وانسحاب من القدس الشرقيه عاصمه دوله
فلسطين وكل ذلك الان لا احد يتحدث عن ذلك
والامر الثالث وهو بالطبع التغلغل
الاقتصادي في سياق ما يمكن ان يشكل ايضا
انفراج الاقتصاد الاحتلالي الذي هو محاصر
الان
امام
انتشار الكورونا في المنطقه وفي العالم
وايضا هذا الامر يعطيه انفراجه حقيقيه على
صعيد التبادل الاقتصادي وانفراج على
المستوى الاقتصادي هي الثلاث عوامل هو
الذي يتحدث عنها لذلك انا بعتقد يعني لا
هذا بالنسبه للاحتلال اما بالنسبه للبحرين
لا اعتقد ان هناك ايه امكانيه الحديث عن
اي مكتسبات سوى انها تقدم اوراق اعتماد
كما جرى مع الامارات اعماد الولايات
المتحده الا الفلسطينيين اتحدث عن يعني هي
من المرات القليله التي يقف فيها الطيف
الفلسط صيني صفا واحدا مقابل هذه
الاتفاقات ما هي خياراتكم سيد واصل ما هي
خيارات الفلسطينيين وعلى ماذا يراهنون ما
هي الاوراق بيد الفلسطينيين
الان ي يعني انا بعتقد ليست المره الاولى
التي تعرض لها القضيه الفلسطينيه الا
مؤامرات الصفويه وتجاوزنا ذلك من خلال
اولا صمود الشعب الفلسطيني على هذه الارض
الفلسطينيه والان الشعب الفلسطيني موحد
كما قلنا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه محتله
جميعا في مخيمات الجو والشات واينما تواجد
الشعب الفلسطيني يستمد استمرار نضاله
وكفاحه من احرار العالم ليس فقط على صعيد
الدول المجاوره وغيرها ولكن على صعيد كل
المتضامنين واحرار العالم الذين يقفوا الى
جانب نضال الشعب الفلسطيني نحن نستند الى
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه والق الدولي نستند
الى رفض اي مساس بهذه الحقوق ونستمر في
كفاحنا ونضالنا مستندين الى عداله قضيتنا
والى ايضا وقوف العديد من دول العالم الى
جانب مضار شعبنا فلسطيني دعيني اشير
بالعجاله الى مساله هامه على سبيل المثال
عندما كانت هناك سياسه الضمه الاحتلالي
التي جاءت في اطار الاتفاق الحكومي بين
نتنياهو وكانز وجدنا من خلال التحركات
التي اجرتها القياده الفلسطينيه مع معظم
دول العالم ان كل دول العالم ضد سياسه
الضمه الاحتلال كانت الدوله الوحيده التي
تقف الى جانب ذلك هي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا الامر الذي جعل من تراجع
سياسه الضم امرا واقعا ط سيد نور ران
نيرين يعني لطالما تحدث الرئيس ترامب عن
اعاده ابناء الولايات المتحده الى حضن
امريكا وهو ربط اليوم بين هذه الاتفاقيات
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل وعوده القوات
الامريكيه الى الى اراضيها
فيعني هل هذه الاتفاقات هي مصلحه امريكيه
ام مصلحه لدول الشرق الاوسط في
النهايه اعتقد ان هذه مصلحه للجميع من
السلام والاستقرار هنالك مزايا
اقتصاديه التجاريه والى ما هنالك ورئيس
ترامب اوضح وقال ان القوات الامريكيه لا
يريدها ان تنخرط في الشرق الاوسط وهو حاول
ان يتفاوض بشان انسحاب القوات من
افغانستان وغيرها من الدول لذلك الجانب
الامريكي يريد ان يرى شرق اوسط مستقر ينعم
بالسلام وهذه خطوه في ذلك الاتجاه البحرين
ليست بلد كبير ولكنها مهمه لان الاسطور
الخامس يرسو في بحرها وبالتالي ثمت موارد
امريكيه اخرى في بلدان اخرى ولكن الجميع
مستفيد بما في ذلك
الفلسطينيين لكي يغيروا الاطار المفاهيمي
الذي فشلوا فيه لكن هي مصلحه للجميع لكن
ما مدى ارتباطها ب يعني وعود انتخابيه
للرئيس الامريكي يعني لماذا ترامب يتحرك
الان بعد اربع اربع سنوات في في في البيت
الابيض يتحرك في الربع ساعه
الاخير نعم اعتقد ان هذه جهود تستغرق وقتا
لكي تاتي اكلها طبعا هذا الرئيس لم ينخرط
في السياسه من ذي قبل وقد امضى وقتا لبناء
العلاقات مع زعماء مختلفين لا اعتقد ان
هذا سوف يفيد الانتخابات البته لان
الانتخابات الامريكيه لا تعتمد على قرارات
السياسات الخارجيه وهناك قضايا مختلفه
ملحه في اذهان الشعب الامريكي هذه الصفقه
وهذا الاتفاق وترتبت الاخرى التي توصل
اليها مرتبطه باستحقاقات هي وهي ذات مزايا
غير مرتبطه بالسياسه الداخليه ولا اعتقد
ان هذا سوف يفضي الى تعزيز مزيه ترامب في
في الانتخابات دكتور توفيق حميد في واشنطن
اعود لك يعني الملفت ان السيسي على سبيل
المثال كان اول المرحبين باتفاق اليوم كما
كان اول المرحبين في الاتفاق الاسرائيلي
الاماراتي كيف نفهم يعني هذا
الترحيب المسبق
المتسارع بالمقارنه مع الدول العربيه
الاخرى في الاقليم في
المنطقه شكرا على سؤالك سيدتي اعتقد ان هو
الرد ليس متسارع ولكن جاء بسرعه لانه
محسوب من ذ قبل يعني زي كلاعب الشطر انجلي
بيلعب نقله سريعه جدا لانه ايه مدرك وعامل
تحليل كافي للايه للدور فالرئيس السيسي
وجد وراى واقع ان السلام جاء بخير لمصر
وزي
ما اذا يبدو ان الاتصال قد انقطع مع
الكتور توفيق حميد سوف نعود له حال ما
يتوافر هذا الاتصال اعود اذا الى ضيفي سيد
واصل اذا من رام الله واتحدث هنا سيد واصل
عن يعني تحدثنا مسبقا عن خيارات
الفلسطينيين نتحدث الان عن ماذا يمكن ان
يقوم به الفلسطينيون الان في المرحله
القادمه الجامعه العربيه فشلت حتى هذه
الساعه حتى اليوم في ادانه اي خطوه
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل على ماذا
تعويل يعني انا بعتقد يعني يجب ان نحاكم
مساله ا بشكل شمولي العديد من الدول
الوازن في العالم تقف الى جانب حقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني على قاعده تطبيق قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه والقانون الدولي وبالوصول الى
اهميه قيام دوله فلسطينيه على الاراضي
المحتله بعدوان 67 والقدس عاصمه لها وضمان
حق العوده للاجئين حسب قرم 194 لا ننسى ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليست قدرا في
العالم هناك الاتحاد الروسي هناك الصين
هناك الدول اوروبا هناك دول عدم انحياز
الدول الافريقيه الدول الاسلاميه العديد
من الدول العربيه وايضا لا يشكل هذا
التطبيع الذي جرى سواء مع الامارات او
البحرين هو نهايه المطاف نحن كشعب فلسطيني
كما قلت قبل قليل تعرضنا الى العديد من
المؤمرات الصفويه بوحدتنا بتعزيز صمودنا
على الارض باستمرار كفاحنا ونضالنا بقياده
منظمه التحليل الفلسطينيه الممثل الشرعي
الوحيد للشعب الفلسطيني الخيمه التي تضل
كل الشعب الفلسطيني والتي لها اوسع
العلاقات في العالم هذا الامر سنستمر في
كفاحنا والتمسك بحقوقنا حتى ن حريه
واستقرار شعبنا الفلسطيني لا يمكن ان نيس
ولا يمكن ان نرفع الرايه البيضاء سمعت قبل
قليل الحديث عن ميزات لا علاقه بهذا
الاتفاق وهذا كلام هو ظل الرمات في العيون
لا ليس ليس له اي من الحقائق الحقيقه
الاساسيه التي يجب ان ننتبه لها ان تغلغل
الصهيوني في المنطقه يحاول الاستفراد
واستغلال كل موارد المنطقه والاستحواذ على
دول هذه المنطقه هناك تبعيه لهذه الدول مع
الاحتلال الذي كما هو معروف التغلغل
الصهيوني ليس نحو الشرق وربما لبعض الدول
العربيه وربما يعني لا نستغرب فيما لو
هرولت بعض الدول العربيه الاخرى يعني
اليوم البحرين
والتي قد تعتبر مؤشر على ربما توجه عربي
اخر نحو التطبيع العمل العربي المشترك هل
ما زال هناك امل فيه او مجال له وماذا عن
مصير المبادره العربيه التي تقوم على مبدا
الارض مقابل
السلام يعني دعيني اشير مساله هامه ان
يعني الصراحه يجب ان تقال اليوم ان
الجامعه العربيه لم ترتقي الى مستوى هذه
التحديات منذ اللحظه الاولى التي اعلن عن
اتفاق الثلاثي الاماراتي الامريكي
الاحتلالي كنا نطالب بعقد قمه طارئه
للجامعه العربيه لاتخاذ موقف واضح وجدي
ازاء الامارات وحتى نقطع الطريق على ايه
امكانيه الحديثه على المراغنه على دول
اخرى تم التهرب من ذلك لعقد الاجتماع في
التاسع من هذا الشهر الاجتماع العادي
براسه دوله ف لين وكما هو معروف العديد من
الدول اجهضت مشروع القرار الذي قدم حول
ادانه الامارات الامر الذي جعل من استمرار
هذا التطبيع للعديد من الدول الاخرى امرا
واقعا وهذا الامر الذي ناسف له لذلك انا
لا اعتقد ان على الرغم من البيان الذي صدر
عن الجامعه العربيه الذي يؤكد على مركزيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه وعلى التمسك بالمبادره
ولكن هذا الامر هو نظريا فقط على صعيد
البيانات كما جرى التاكيد عليه في كل
دورات الجامعه العربيه سواء القمم العربيه
او م رات وزراه الخارجيه او غيرها لذلك
انا بعتقد يجب اعاده النظر حتى في موضوع
الجامعه العربيه لا يمكن القبول بان تقوم
تقوم دول باختراق ميثاق الجامعه العربيه
ولا يكون هناك محاسبه لها ولا يمكن ولا
يجري مناقشه هذا الامر بجديه على صعيد
الجامعه العربيه فبالتالي لا عن اي جامعه
نتحدث الجامعه
بصراحه ثبت بالملموس ان خواء يسيطر على
هذه الجامعه وبصراحه تعطي ضوء اخضر وغطاء
لعمليات التطبيع التي جري لانها لم تاخذ
مواقف جاده وحقيقيه ترتقي الى مستوى هذا
التطبيع نحن من جانبنا كفلسطينيين لا يمكن
ان نسكت عن اي دوله تطبع مع الاحتلال
سنبقى نعتبر ذلك طعننا في ظاهر نضال الشعب
الفلسطيني وخيان القضيه الفلسطينيه وقضايا
ايض سيد واصل انضم الينا الان من الكويت
عبر الانترنت صالح المطيري رئيس مركز
المدار للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
سيد صالح يعني بعد رفض الجامعه العربيه
ادانه قرار التطبيع او اتفاقيات التطبيع
هذه هل نحن بصدد نظام عربي
جديد ربما منظومه شرق اوسطيه جديده يقول
البعض قد تقودها اسرائيل
الان يعني بالتاكيد خبر اليوم لم يكن
مفاجئا لكثير من المراقبين والمحللين
وكانت هناك يعني اشاره واضحه عندما تبنت
مملكه البحرين كاول دوله ايدت الاتفاق
الاماراتي الاسرائيلي وكان هذا مؤشر حقيقه
على انه سوف تكون هي الدوله الثانيه ضمن
هذا البرنامج والذي يعني ربما افضل وصف له
هو ان ترامب رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قد فتح هذا الملف ليكون ملفا
انتخابيا باستحقاق
واستخدم هذه الحكومات للاسف الشديد لكي
تكون ضمن برنامج الانتخابي واستخدم هذا
الملف التطبيعي مع اسرائيل ليكون يعني
احدى الادوات المهمه التي ربما ترفع من
دعمه او فرص نجاحه في الانتخابات المقبله
لن اعول كثيرا على جامعه الدول العربيه
بالفعل كان ربما البيان الاخير للاجتماع
الدوري كان مخيبا لامال الكثيرين خصوصا
وان فلسطين هي التي تراست هذا الاجتماع في
محاوله منها حقيقه لاستصدار بيان لكن انا
اعتقد بانه لم يكن متوقعا من هذه الجامعه
نتيجه هذه الضغوط سواء دوله المقر او
الممول الرئيسي لميزانيه الجامعه العربيه
يخولها كي تستط ان تصدر مثل هذا البيان او
تطالب على الاقل ولو باستحياء بتبني
المبادره العربيه على الاقل يعني كان هذا
متوقعا ان تقول بان المبادره العربيه ما
زالت قائمه نحو سلام عادل وشامل مع
اسرائيل يضمن الحقوق الفلسطينيه العادله
والكامله او الحد الادنى من هذه الحقوق
الحد الادنى من هذه الحقوق الامارات
العربيه تحدثت عن هذه الحدود الدنيا او
الحد الادنى من هذه الحقوق الفلسطينيه
وربطت
اا
مقف على
الاقل اتضح بعد ذلك غير هذا الكلام
البحرين برايك بماذا
تبرر هذا
التطبيع نفس المبررات التي سيقت يعني انا
اعتقد هذه المبررات سيقت منذ 78 منذ
الاتفاق الاول اللي كان ديفيد لكن في تلك
الفتره كانت رده الفعل يعني الوضع ربي لم
يكن كما هو الحال الان نتيجه ظروف كثيره
لكن انا اعتقد بانه اي من المبررات التي
سيقت لم تجد حقيقه في البدايه قبولا لدى
شعوب هذه يعني اليوم لو تلاحظي الشارع
البحريني ك يعني اكثر ما صدر منه رفض هذه
الاتفاقيه او رفض هذا الاندفاع البحريني
تجاه التطبيع واعتقد بانه كثير من
التعليقات وكثير من الاصوات التي ارتفعت
في البحرين ترفض مثل هذا التطبيع او ترفض
هذه التبريرات حقيقه التي سيقت بانها من
اجل القضيه انا اعتقد بانه الاتجاه
الفرادي نحو اسرائيل او نحو التطبيع مع
الكيان الصوني لن يخدم القضيه على الاقل
الان لو توقفنا اخذنا نفسا عميقا كما يقال
وانت هذه على الجانب الاخر هل يمكن ان
يخدم اسرائيل ويجعلها بلدا يعني مقبولا في
الشرق
الاوسط شوفي القبول الرسمي لن يعول عليه
كثير وانا ما زلت يعني عند كلامي منذ منذ
فتره يعني وانه ان نجحت اسرائيل في
التطبيع مع الحكومات لن تستطيع ان تنجح في
التطبيع مع الشعوب واسرائيل بالتاكيد
يهمها ان تطبع مع الشعوب العربيه او ان
تكون مقبوله لدى الشارع العربي او الراي
العام العربي بالتاكيد هذه الاتفاقيات
الفرديه تخدم اسرائيل تخدم حكومه اليمين
الاسرائيلي في هذه المرحله وان اعلنت
الدول المطبعه بانه مثل هذه الاتفاقيات
اوقفت او فرملت الحكومه الاسرائيليه تجاه
ضم الاراضي او اعتبار الاراضي في الضفه
الغربيه اراضي فلسطينيه او التوسع في
المستعمرات
وبالتالي ضم الاراضي انا اعتقد بانه
المبادره العربيه لا زالت قائمه اعول على
موقف المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى هذه
اللحظه الخطاب الرسمي او ما جاء من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى هذه اللحظه
متمسك بالحقوق الشرعيه الفلسطينيه بالحل
العادل وتمسك حتى هذه الل ايض بالمبادره
العرب المبادره العربيه الموقف السعودي
تحدث عن تمسكه في المبادره العربيه لكن
كون البحرين الان وم معروف العلاقه
الوثيقه بين البحرين والسعوديه المك العيه
السوديه هل يمكن لهذا الاتفاق ان يعد او
يعتبر مؤشرا على ربما خطوه اخرى تحدث عنها
الرئيس ترامب ربما ان تسير على نفس الخطى
دول عربيه اخرى هل يمكن ان تكون السعوديه
ربما تسير على خطا البحرين بعد ذلك مؤشر
على ذلك لا انا ما اعتقد ما زلت يعني على
قناعه تامه بانه لا ات المغفور له طيب
الذكر الملك فيصل بن عبد العزيز عندما ذكر
في خطاب الشهير بان المملكه ستكون مهما
تقدم نحو اسرائيل من دول العربيه لن تكون
من ضمنهم المملكه العربيه السعوديه وانا
اعتقد بانه فشل ترامب وزياره كوشنر
الاخيره حتى مع السودان التي كانت الى حد
ما اعلاميه مستعجله او متعجل في التطبيع
لم تنجح وكان موقف رئيس الوزراء السوداني
قويا بالرغم من انه يبدو انه العسكر في في
السودان لديهم هذا التوجه فعدم نجاحهم في
السودان اعتقد مؤشر كبير بانه لن ينجحوا
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه وانا اعتقد
بان المملكه العربيه السعوديه حكومه
وشعبا لديها بالتاكيد معايير كبيره ولديها
ايضا محاذير كثيره تجاه التطبيع مع
اسرائيل في هذه الفتره اعتقد بان من
الحكمه الانتظار حتى تعدي او نتجاوز
الانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله وان لا نكون
مفاتيح انتخابيه لترامب في في حملته
الانتخابيه المقبله واعتقد ايضا من الحكمه
ان تتريث الحكومات بالرغم من اعلان ترامب
بانه هناك حكومات عربيه مقبله لعمل مثل
هذه الاتفاقيات الفرديه مع اسرائيل لكن
يعني لدينا بيص امل بان ستتمسك المملكه
العربيه بالحقوق الشرعيه والعاد للشعب
الفلسطيني وايضا تتمسك بالمبادره العربيه
التي يعني اعطت لاسرائيل فرصه تاريخيه
حقيقه بان يكون هناك سلام شامل وعادل مع
كل الدول العربيه وتطبيع ايضا رسمي وشعبي
اذا ما اعطت للفلسطينيين حقوقهم الدنيا
واعترفت باراضيها 67 وا واقت كل هذه ملفات
انا اتصور انه الان نعطي الفلسطينيين فرصه
على الاقل يشموا الانفاس لندع الفلسطينيين
يحاولوا ان يكونوا يعني متمسكين بحقوقهم
ويجب ان نخذلهم اكثر من هذا الخذلان شكرا
لك سيد صالح المطيري المحلل السياسي ورئيس
مركز المدار كنت معنا من الكويت واشكر
ايضا عبر الانترنت رون نيرين الرئيس
السابق للحزب الجمهوري في كاليفورنيا
واشكرك سيد واصل ابو يوسف عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه كنت
معنا من رام الله واشكر الدكتور توفيق
حميد الباحث والمحلل السياسي كان معنا
ايضا من العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن